[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Charles Barkley said to join us uh Todd
is oh he's ready to go Chuck there all
right
Chuck how are you
I'm good brother how you doing what's
your philosophy when people want an
autograph like when when is it a good
time and when is it a bad time to
approach you
uh you should sign autographs
uh just when you're eating is not
appropriate but I think part of your
responsibility
they don't pay you all that money just
to play basketball so I think you should
always sound autographs I always sign
autograph unless I'm eating
but you get swarmed though don't you
yeah but yeah I do but listen man These
Guys these people pay us millions and
millions of dollars
to play a stupid game to take a couple
minutes and it further it has to be
quick hey I don't want to hear no
stories no no yo man give me the paper
let me sign it yeah I you know I don't
want to hear the stories I I don't care
so so that's to me it's the only time
it's a problem I don't want to hear no
stories just tell me hey give me the
paper
and I sign it how often do you ask for
an autograph or a picture
it it I have you know uh I collect
memorabilia I got a great hockey
collection
I got a great basketball collection of
different pitchers and like but if I met
somebody
um you know I I would be happy to take a
picture I mean I'm I'm a fan boy to some
people
like when you meet Gretzky you ask for
it yeah I got a Gretzky stick got my
favorite hockey players Ron heckstall my
favorite football player was Brian
Dawkins they gave me a signed jersey I
somebody found out they were big I was a
big fan they gave me a signed jersey in
the last couple years anybody disappoint
you
not really uh you know I think well
because obviously has something to do
with who I am
uh but hey I got celebrity friends who
won't sign autographs
I mean I got a couple of friends who say
hey I hate to bother you then don't damn
bother me
you know so but but I tell people this
because people ask me about hey I walked
up this guy I said well that probably
didn't go well yeah I think it's up to
the individual if they want to sign
autographs and we're not on the same
level I mean I know some guys who are
bigger than me who don't sign stuff but
they probably get bugged more than me
but my personal opinion is I'm gonna
always sign autographs I think it goes
with the responsibility
when you run 60 Minutes you mentioned
the uh friendship or what was a
friendship with Michael Jordan
did you hear from Jordan
no no that was so funny I've never had
more people ask me about to do they act
like we press Wayne and Prince Harry uh
hey Mike Michael I love Michael like a
brother he's doing great I'm doing great
he got mad at me it's no big deal I
think we're both uh man I'm sweating
over here but it's it's it's unfortunate
but man I wish him nothing but the best
I hope he's doing great uh but hey it's
it's unfortunate
well I know you came on this show and
you said he's not a good owner Mike's
not a good owner
well well I didn't say he wasn't a good
owner I said he didn't have good enough
people around he was surrounded by Yes
Men yes yes and and I said that and it
was true and he went ballistic but hey
man you know Dan one of the reasons I've
been very good at my job I don't just
I'm not gonna say one of the reason I
hate reporters to be honest with you
guys like Skip Bayless and people like
that
you can tell the guys they like and
dislike that ain't right you should be
fair I'm not gonna because just because
me and Michael were great friends I
don't give him a hall pass the one thing
I've been straightforward and honest on
anybody I've given my opinion with uh in
my third 23 years I never played
favorites there's nobody can say Charles
don't like this guy I've been fair to
everybody
uh as far as the NBA home stretcher how
do you think this plays out
man nobody got zero idea um
is there a great team
no there's not a great team at all okay
there's some great players but I tell
you what man the West is going to be
crazy
it's going to go down to the last day of
the season I mean the East is set and we
know who's going to be like it's going
to come down to Boston Milwaukee and
Philly those three teams they're they're
above everybody else but in the West
I can't wait for the West uh this
weekend I can't wait for the first round
matchups I mean it could be the the
Lakers could play the Sacramento Kings
or they could play the Denver Nuggets in
the first round of the playoffs
uh I don't know who gonna win the West
if you hold my feet to the fire imma
stick with the Denver Nuggets they've
been the most consistent Team all year
but as they say though I'm gonna write
it in pencil I'm not gonna write it in
pen
who's your MVP
man I'm glad I don't have a vote
uh to be honest with you I don't think
there's a wrong wrong answer
if I had a vote why don't you have a
vote
I don't know uh Ernie's the only guy on
our show who has a vote
uh it it probably come down to embiid
and Giannis if I had a vote
uh
because I think that
I I I'm like I say I would and like I
say there's no right or wrong answer if
you vote for Joker uh Giannis or Joelle
I don't think there's a wrong answer but
if I had a vote it'd come down to Joelle
and Giannis
and I'd probably give it to Joelle
because he's never won before
you know what really bothers me is these
guys on television who act like well you
know they we will
they'd be saying well this guy should
have wanted x amount of time it's never
been about that it's always been Michael
Jordan was the best player probably
three or four years before he won his
first MVP just not on a good team nobody
thinks Steve Nash was better than Kobe
or Shaq but he had a better regular
season
it's a regular season award
if I had to pick the best player in the
NBA today I'd probably go with Giannis
but like I say it it's never went to the
best player but these guys on television
like well this guy they tired of giving
it to the same guy no they give it to
the guy who had the best regular season
it's not who wins the championship or
who plays great in the playoffs that's
who played the best in those during the
regular season where's your MVP right
now your award
it's actually the only award that I got
to be honest with you because you know
I'm selling all my memorabilia to be on
the underprivileged houses in my
hometown I was supposed to do it before
the pandemic because I don't that stuff
like that don't matter to me but
my daughter I asked her
what she wanted she asked for one of the
she said I'll take one of the gold
medals and the rest of this crap I'm
gonna sell for underprivileged houses in
my hometown dude that stuff is just
clutter to me Dan everybody know I won
MVP everybody know I won gold medals
dude let me tell you something I I'm 60
years old Dan
if if people come to the house and I say
hey let's go look at my MVP trophy and
look at my gold medal all right I'm the
biggest damn loser in the world
see think about that Dan
if if you were and you you and the
nerdettes come to the house like yeah
come on I'm gonna take you all over here
and look at my MVP trophy and my gold
medal I'm Gonna Be The Biggest Loser in
the world
but I would want to see those things
yeah I mean they're worth seeing one
time but you can't like no I'm gonna get
rid of those things because hey man
everybody know I want a couple of gold
medals and MVP I don't you don't have to
tell people but if you go to tiger's
house
does he have all of his Majors all of
his trophies there
I've actually
I've been to his house but I haven't
been to his new house and at that time I
think he only had like two or three
Majors back then okay so but I think
that's different Dan
but those trophies are humongous yeah
and uh but no no I haven't been seeing a
but he you probably got to show those
off
so wait a minute does did he lose half
of his memorabilia when he got divorced
I don't know the answer to that question
hey I think I think I think he would I
think he would prefer to have a cast
instead of a U.S open trophy
but have you gone into somebody's house
and they and they have a shrine to
themselves
great question I don't think so I think
most guys because the way it really
works Dan you're really trying to get to
your next next accomplishment
you don't really like when I was winning
my mom and grandmother kept them all I
said hey take this this thing they're
like you don't want it I said no I want
the next one because you are you're
always going and going and let's be
realistic there's very few things like
if I was going to be honest with you my
MVP trophy and my two gold medals would
probably be the only two things Worth
showing
I mean all those other things
um like player of the Week player of the
month you put those in paperweights man
you don't keep up with those things how
much is the MVP going to cost me
that's a great question I don't know
um I don't know how it's so crazy how
signed an autographs and things but if I
give you twenty five thousand dollars
for them you're not gonna get you ain't
gonna get a finger you're not even going
you're not even gonna get one of the
legs you're not even gonna get one of
their legs on the MVP trophy for 25 000.
come on Dan all right all right all
right
what can I get for twenty five thousand
dollars
like
oh uh a player of the month
come on Dan you were never named
defensive player of the month that's for
sure I was not a good uh I was a decent
Defender okay explain this to me when
when we talk about the like Luca and
Kyrie
they they can't play defense or they
won't play defense because I don't
unders like Sacramento Kings they can
score but they're not good at defense
how are you not good at defense because
it's probably defense and rebounding are
probably the two hardest aspects of
basketball could they take
a lot of work
they take a lot of work score it is easy
all you gotta do is shoot the ball a lot
but if you're gonna play defense you got
to really get down and dirty you got to
get and same thing with rebounding you
got to get in there and start beating up
people because it's like yo got the
ball's the most valuable thing out there
so if you're going to be a great
rebounder you're gonna have to take some
beatings and on defense
man trying to stop a guy's hard
I mean you think about the guys you're
trying to stop
I mean just take Luca and Kyrie both
great one-on-one basketball players
they ain't a job people apply for
nobody says hey let me stop Kyrie or
Luca
uh but you know this thing was never you
know they when it first happened they
asked us on the air like this is never
gonna work it's a bad idea
they both need to ball
it was never going to work and
um hey it's going to be a very
interesting off season yeah for that for
that team would you sign Kyrie if you're
Dallas
oh no it's not going well what's the
really good thing about it
for Dallas they got two really good
options they can let him go and take 40
million dollars off the books and I
think they're only going to be paying
Luca so they might can get a free agent
but the best option to me is to do a
sign and trade because Dallas can give
him the most money
and some team will take Kyrie and
they'll give and to make the money match
they probably go they're going to give
you a bunch of good players and draft
picks so yeah but he was going to want
Kyrie
somebody Dan somebody gonna want Kyrie
everybody think everybody think they can
fix somebody
he's a great individual player some
coach some team gonna think they can
like okay we can make this work I mean
this is like his third or fourth team
somebody always gonna think like and it
is and it hasn't worked but there's
always a team that's going to say hey
you know what I think I can make this
work so even though I hated to trade for
Dallas I think in the long run it could
be a good thing whether they take him
off the books or do a sign and trade
talking to Charles Barkley the Hall of
Famer uh when's the last time you went
to the Masters
I've never been to the Masters
uh I've never been there you know Dan
when I go out to things like that people
think I'm there to talk to them they
don't realize I'm never actually they
don't realize I'm actually there to
watch the sporting event
you know so so it's better for me I love
the Masters have you played Augusta I
did I played last year during the
playoffs it was one of the coolest
experiences of my life
uh I shot a 89.
I played well I was so excited I was so
nervous it was an honor and a privilege
uh but Hey listen I'm rooting for the
live guys this weekend because I think
these PGA Tour dues have been too rough
on these lib guys I think the disrespect
they've shown Phil Mickelson is
ridiculous they should be kissing his
ass to be honest with you because Phil
has made those guys more money in the
last year and a half they got they made
I mean they should be thanking him but
the way they've been crapping all over
these live guys it's been disappointing
hey Dan
they left for another Economic
Opportunity I'm not mad at them you know
about three or four of those guys called
called me and asked me my opinion I said
yo man let's don't get into this where
our money comes from because if
everybody want to sit around and worry
about where our money comes from nobody
gonna be working
I mean nobody's gonna be working so I
told those guys man take that money
screw those screw those guys who gonna
bad mouth it but I just think the PGA
Tour has been overboard criticizing
these guys and I want to live guys and
play well and I want one of them to win
it if I gave Phil Mickelson a mulligan
to stay on the PGA tour or go to live
he should go to live
you think that if I gave him a do-over
he would still go to live tour
Dana somebody gave me 200 million
dollars I'd go anywhere
I'm probably going to hell anyway but
200 million dollars for 200 billion
dollars if I had a chance to go to
heaven and hell give me 200 million I'm
going to hell
no I know I feel you know those guys all
feel a great deal of gratitude because
you notice all of a sudden the PJ tour
came up with billions of dollars to pay
these players now yeah just because of
Phil
so instead of crap I don't feel like
they've been doing I think they should
say hey you know what maybe we don't
agree with you guys going to live but we
understand
I mean we all leave for better Economic
Opportunity and I don't like this fake
outrage about oh they're taking money
from Saudi Arabia I mean we're all
taking money from somebody that we
probably shouldn't be taking it from
are you a grandfather now I am and it's
the greatest thing ever little Henry
um little Henry Man Dan I'm telling you
man it's the greatest thing ever been a
grandpa
um I just became one about six weeks ago
congratulations man yep any damn weight
when they start developing a little
personality now my man just started he
just turned one like last week now he's
starting to walk and like he notices my
face I Face Time him and everything like
that wait it gets so much better Dad I
can't wait I think like I'm going home
for a couple days and we off until the
uh play in tournament Tuesday
and I'm gonna take him out on a golf
cart
uh for the first time this weekend and I
can't wait
if you could pick the sport that you
want him to play what would it be
well obviously that'd be basketball but
probably golf I love golf I love being
outside it's one of the few places
people you know I like to play golf and
fish because it's like only two places
you can go and people don't want to bug
the hell out of you so golf golf would
be uh my thing but as long as he's a
good person you know you know I was
thinking about
um the Wayans family the other day
and I saw one of the Wayne's brothers
did a tribute to his
dad and it was really profound and he
said son he asked his dad dad what you
want me to be he said a man
and he says well everybody grows up to
be a man he says that ain't even close
to the truth and I thought that was so
profound and it really made me take a
step back like yeah man you you want
your kids to grow up
and you want to be proud of them like
I'm really proud of my daughter because
she's a nice person she's a great mother
and you know I'm just really so you you
want to make your parents proud and my
daughter has done that so as long as
little Henry's a good person I'm good
Grandpa Barkley sounds like a show on
TNT a sitcom well first of all just a
record I'm big pop uh
not Big Poppy or big papa oh big big Pop
I stole that from some to guy I was
giving Ernie a an award Last Summer
and this cute little girl comes up to me
and says hey Mr Barker can I take a
picture I say of course who gonna take
the picture she says my big pop next
thing I know this little dude is walking
toward me who's there she said oh that's
big Pop I said well damn this dude like
five five if he can be big Pop I know I
could be big pop and I said so that's
gonna be my name when little Henry gets
old enough I like it big pop uh great to
talk to you and enjoy your days off safe
travels thanks again thank you brother
hey Dan keep up the great work brother
thanks for having me Charles Barkley
will take a break if you're watching on
peacock we'll check out the Traeger
Grills and uh last call for phone calls
after this